[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg
guten abend und willkommen zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem samstag
zara ist auch dabei für den sport hallo
schön genannt und wir haben unter
anderem diese themen für sie
hinter der frontlinie der kampf der
ärzte um das leben verwundete soldaten
in der ost ukraine
pazifismus oder panzer die grünen sagen
ja zu schweren waffen für die ukraine
und 45 grad und mehr die menschen in
indien leiden unter einer rekordhitze
tag 66 des ukraine kriegs nach
einschätzung der nato stockt die
russische offensive im osten des landes
der ukrainische präsident sie lenski
spricht von wichtigen taktischen
erfolgen seines militärs doch auch die
verluste dürften schlimm sein russland
hat nach eigenen angaben fast 400 ziele
getroffen und 120 ukrainische soldaten
getötet in der ost ukraine direkt hinter
der frontlinie liegt das militärhospital
in lizenz von dort kommt die reportage
eines französischen kamerateams
christoph distel hat sie für uns
bearbeitet
der rauch von am horizont das ist der
krieg ukrainische soldaten die dort in
den schützengräben verletzt werden die
aber noch transportfähig sind komm ins
krankenhaus von lisicki auch dieser mann
der von schrapnell kugeln getroffen
wurde die befürchtung vielleicht stecken
noch welche im kopf ein erster check
wie heißt du sagte einen namen der mann
ist bei bewusstsein und bekommt ein ct
dann die entwarnung es ist nichts
schlimmes
15 verletzte seit dem morgen zählen die
pfleger nicht alle kämen so glimpflich
davon weiß der behandelnde arzt
das artilleriefeuer zertrümmert knochen
zerreißt arterien reist fleischwunden
wir müssen viel amputieren
um weitere verletzte von der front zu
holen macht sich tatiana eine der
krankenschwestern fertig für die fahrt
packt schmerzmittel ein und solche gegen
blutungen vor allem die seien
lebenswichtig
meist verlieren die männer viel blut und
könnten schon allein daran sterben nicht
nur soldaten kommen an der front ums
leben seit einigen tagen trauern die
schwestern des krankenhauses um ihre
kollegin irina sie starb im
artilleriefeuer
es ist erschütternd ihre zwei kinder
sind jetzt weisen uns fällt schwer
darüber zu sprechen
ans aufgeben denkt hier trotzdem niemand
ein soldat plan schon seinen nächsten
einsatz obwohl seine fußverletzung noch
lange nicht ausgeheilt ist
da drüben sind jungs von uns gestorben
und ich lebe noch natürlich gehe ich
zurück
man kann es mut mit pflichterfüllung
oder unvernunft aber so wie der krieg
gerade läuft sehen sie zumindest im
krankenhaus von musik tanz keinen
anderen weg
fragen wir dara hassanzadeh in nico wie
bewertet die ukrainische seite die
russische offensive was hören sie denn
auch der ukrainische generalstab sagt
dass die russische offensive nicht
vorankommt doch keine 150 kilometer von
hier entfernt am südlichen
frontabschnitt gibt es heftigen
artilleriebeschuss das könnten russische
vorbereitung sein um dort die front zu
durchbrechen und um dann der nach später
richtung der stadt schöpferischer
vorzurücken
jeden tag wird mehr von diesem land
zerstört wie ist das bei ihnen vor ort
spürbar
in den letzten tagen hatten wir nur
luftalarm und es gab keine luftangriffe
doch die getroffenen treibstofflager im
land die wirken sich nun aus neun von
zehn tankstellen hier und nico sind
geschlossen und dort wo es diesel gibt
dort sind die langen schlangen
dankeschön für diese andere kostenniveau
dara hassanzadeh war das finden
um die verteidigungsfähigkeit der
ukraine zu erhöhen haben die amerikaner
damit begonnen ukrainische soldaten auch
in deutschland auszubilden zum beispiel
im umgang mit schweren waffen wie
haubitzen
im moment gibt es kaum hoffnung auf
schnellen frieden verschiedene szenarien
wie putins krieg enden könnte finden sie
bei zdf heute und in unserer app
cdu-chef märz plant nach
zdf-informationen eine reise in die
ukraine auch nach kiew zeitnah der
genaue termin ist nicht bekannt ob er
präsident selensky treffen wird steht
noch nicht fest den grünen verlangt
dieser krieg besondere flexibilität ab
eigentlich war die partei ja mal fest
verankert in der friedensbewegung
doch längst fordern nicht nur die
zuständigen minister vehement die
lieferung von schweren waffen in die
ukraine auf dem kleinen parteitag galt
es heute die basis bei dieser kehrtwende
mitzunehmen patricia wiedemeier und
thaddäus parade berichten der kleine
parteitag der grünen er findet in
düsseldorf statt dort wo bald gewählt
wird doch die ukraine überlagert alles
auf landtagswahlen die grünen sie haben
sich von anfang an klar und deutlich für
waffenlieferungen eingesetzt dies
widerspreche nicht dem prinzipien einer
pazifistischen partei finanziell
humanitär wirtschaftlich braucht die
ukraine unsere unterstützung aber sie
braucht sie hat auch mit waffen und zwar
auch mit schwereren waffen wir schauen
da als regierungspartei der realität ins
gesicht und reagieren auf das was
passiert und wir werden immer
friedenspartei bleiben
wirtschaftsminister habeck und
außenministerin baerbock beide
zugeschaltet haben früh und vehement die
lieferung schwerer waffen gefordert auch
wenn es grünen schwer falle dabei
handeln wir und habe dann zugleich und
wir hadern ob wir ausreichend handeln
wir sind in der lage unsere realisierung
zu verändern wenn sich die wirklichkeit
verändert aber das ist ja ein
qualitätsmerkmal und nichts wofür man
sich entschuldigen muss seien wir also
stolz darauf die delegierten sie folgen
ihrer spitze stimmen mehrheitlich für
waffenlieferungen für das sondervermögen
von 100 milliarden für die bundeswehr
nur dass zwei prozent ziel der nato
wurde abgelehnt verhaltene kritik von
der grünen jugend als grüne jugend sehen
das natürlich noch mal besonders
kritisch und wollen dafür auch sorgen
dass wir danach wieder zu unserem
pazifistischen standpunkt zurück kommen
dass wir uns alle nicht einfach aber ich
nehme trotzdem eine große zustimmung war
weil wir diese verantwortung tragen es
gab hier in düsseldorf große
rückendeckung für den kurs der regierung
streitereien oder gar farbbeutel wie
früher mal beim thema krieg und frieden
sie scheinen der vergangenheit
anzugehören
scharfe kritik an der ukraine politik
der bundesregierung und vor allem des
bundeskanzlers kommt heute von der csu
ein solches zögern sich verstecken sei
eines deutschen kanzlers unwürdig sagte
csu-chef söder beim kleinen parteitag in
würzburg der bundeskanzler drücke sich
davor der deutschen bevölkerung
orientierung zu geben in dieser krise
demonstrationen straßenfeste und
möglicherweise auch krawalle all das
wird an diesem ersten mai wochenende
erwartet in berlin versammelten sich
schon heute in einigen stadtteilen linke
gruppen um für mehr soziale
gerechtigkeit zu protestieren die
meisten veranstaltungen sind für morgen
angekündigt dann auch in vielen weiteren
städten
jetzt corona bevor wir gleich nach china
schauen wo sie gerade die maßnahmen
verschärfen hier erstmal die aktuellen
zahlen aus deutschland
die bundesweite sieben tage incidents
ist erneut gesunken auf 717 4 das robert
koch institut registrierte binnen eines
tages 87 1298 neuinfektionen das sind 47
1781 weniger als vor einer woche
innerhalb eines tages wurden 159
todesfälle erfasst
in china sind die offiziellen zahlen
viel niedriger aber die angst ist
riesengroß vor allem in peking soll
nicht so werden wie in shanghai die 26
millionen einwohner stadt ist wegen
immer mehr omikron fällen seit wochen
abgeriegelt jetzt schließen auch in der
hauptstadt die restaurants und es gibt
neue massentests aus peking berichtet
ulf röller
die behörden testen jeden bürger pekings
22 millionen einwohner hat die stadt
endlose schlangen vor den stationen im
kampf gegen das mikro virus
in den supermärkten hamsterkäufe viele
haben noch die hunger schreie aus
shanghai im gedächtnis um eine
versorgungs katastrophe zu verhindern
hat peking extra viele lebensmittel in
die hauptstadt bringen lassen
ich glaube dass peking besser in der
lage ist die lebensmittelsicherheit zu
gewährleisten
auf diese karte schaut peking sie zeigt
50 infektionsfälle für gestern jeder
einzelne hat dramatische folgen für die
menschen die dort leben und arbeiten wie
hier in davos wurde das geschäftsviertel
lahmgelegt nur die desinfektions teams
arbeiten unermüdlich hier kann man die
härte des lockt das sehen alle geschäfte
sind dicht die hochhäuser dahinter sind
leer die meisten zu dem homeoffice man
kann hier wirklich die angst vor dem
mikro virus spüren
in der hauptstadt sind sie nervös dass
ihre 0 kopp it-strategie zusammenbricht
und panik entsteht
pekings machthaber warnen auf
gigantischen videoleinwänden die
bevölkerung jeder der sich nicht an die
regeln halte oder versuche aus der krise
gewinn zu schlagen komme ins gefängnis
der kampf gegen die pandemie ist ein
krieg ein krieg des widerstandes
ein krieg dem das partyleben der
hauptstadt jetzt zum opfer fällt bars
und restaurants bleiben geschlossen
nachts wird es in peking still
schauen wir nach indien das ist dort
heiß ist ist eigentlich nicht
ungewöhnlich ungewöhnlich ist dass es
jetzt im april schon so heißt es seit
tagen hängt eine gefährliche hitzeglocke
über indien die städte ware glutofen
mehr als 46 grad wurden vielerorts
gemessen für die menschen ist das
lebensgefährlich zeit genommen und
unbarmherzig brennt die sonne und unten
beginnt der müll zu kugeln immer wieder
bricht feuer aus auf dieses riesige
mülldeponie die feuerwehr kommt nicht
nach die hitze setzt leicht entzündliche
gase frei und vorstellbar dass hier
menschen leben und arbeiten den müll
nach verwertbaren durchsuchen auch jetzt
noch wir haben angst wie ratten asse
gase ein das macht uns krank ich habe
schmerzen beim atmen das geht vielen so
und wir können nicht
es ist eine qual auf den straßen dbs die
menschen ohnmächtig gegen die hitze und
manchmal auch wegen ihr seit tagen
herrschen mehr als 40 45 grad und das in
diesen engen moloch bewegen ist keine
gute idee aber es gibt welche die ihnen
bleibt nichts anderes übrig
jeder leidet er bei viralen arbeiten bei
regen kälte und auch bei dieser hitze
sonst können wir nicht überlebt
in den staaten ächzen die menschen auf
den feldern vertrocknet die ernte warum
das ist kein rätsel mehr die
temperaturen steigen hitzewellen nehmen
zu intensität dauer häufigkeit da ist
die wissenschaft klar alles das geht
zurück auf den klimawandel
klimageräte werden am straßenrand zum
kauf angeboten durch diese kühlung
braucht viel strom die netze drohen
zusammenzubrechen auch sie sind
überhitzt
so sah das andere extrem aus bei uns
nach der flutkatastrophe im vergangenen
juli anna und erft sind die
aufräumarbeiten und der wiederaufbau
noch lange nicht abgeschlossen viele
hochwasseropfer warten zusehens
ungeduldig auf unterstützung und auf
finanzielle hilfe aus erftstadt
berichtet jena kann
auch ein dreivierteljahr nach der flut
leben harald reichel und seine frau auf
einer dauerbaustelle die komplette
untere etage in ihrem haus sowie der
keller stehen immer noch im oberhaus
man hat seine sanierung ist von der
versicherung hier und sie sagt ja nach
drei vier monaten ist alles klar aber
die haben so schlecht gearbeitet sie
haben leider sub sub unternehmen aber
auftrag die hatten keine ahnung die
hatten dann hier mit boden stemmen haben
sie an der wand gearbeitet und man sieht
ja was dafür löcher entstanden sind der
wiederaufbau in den flutgebieten
verzögert sich weil handwerker fehlen
genauso wie baumaterialien hier in
erftstadt gibt es für flutopfer wie
harald reiche kostenlose baustoffe die
von firmen gespendet wurden ein helfer
der ersten stunde ist die bosch die er
leitet das hilfsprojekt und flutopfer
beim wiederaufbau zu unterstützen
gibt sehr viele häuser die noch ganz am
anfang stehen und nicht mal der
gutachter vor ort war denn die häuser
begutachten konnte um zu entscheiden wie
geht es weiter über
150 freiwillige helferinnen und helfer
engagieren sich in ihrer freizeit bei
baustoff spenden nrw das durch
spendengelder finanziert wird harald
reichel ist dankbar für diese hilfe denn
obwohl er versichert ist dauerte es
teilweise monate bis er sein geld
bekommt was ist also ideal weil ich kann
jetzt weiterarbeiten kann den leuten
wenn die handwerker kommen auch sagen
was auch ich hab's material da wir sagen
bescheid wenn ihr zeit habt kommt rein
arbeitet für die betroffenen ist der
wiederaufbau ein langer komplizierter
weg helfer und spenden werden in den
flutgebieten noch lange gebraucht
was läuft gut in den flutgebieten was
weniger jener von und angela eppert
haben in nordrhein westfalen und
rheinland pfalz mit betroffenen
gesprochen
ihre reportage schon jetzt in der
mediathek und morgen hier bei uns im tv
um 18 uhr und jetzt live bei unseren tv
das hast du nicht gesehen triumph aus
spanien zunächst real madrid ist zum 35
mal spanischer fußball meister die
königlichen besiegten espanyol barcelona
mühelos mit 4 0 die mannschaft von
trainer carlo ancelotti ist vier
spieltage vor saisonende nicht mehr
einzuholen
und wieder haben sie den meister gemacht
die königlichen von madrid hatten
leichtes spiel schon der anstoß durch
tennis-star rafael nadal war eine
besondere showeinlage vor dem
titelgewinn sechs stammspieler sind
gegen espanyol barcelona nicht auf dem
platz als der brasilianische jungstar
rodrigo zweimal zur 2 0 halbzeitführung
für die b elf von real trifft auch ein
unentschieden hätte gereicht marco
asensio macht lieber noch das 3 0 in der
55 minute bevor der eingewechselte
karina sima erhöht zum 4 0 endstand in
der 81 der 35 triumph des spanischen
rekordmeisters ist perfekt vier tage vor
dem rückspiel im halbfinale der
champions league gegen manchester city
und damit sind wir bei den ergebnissen
des drittletzten spieltages in der
fußball-bundesliga der abstiegskampf
bleibt spannend bayern münchen und
dortmund kassieren überraschende
niederlagen so sieht das im einzelnen
aus meister bayern münchen verliert in
mainz 13 dortmund unterliegt trotz der
drei holland tore bochum 3 zu 4 köln sid
deutlich 4 1 in augsburg 1 zu 1 im
abstiegsduell bielefeld gegen hertha bsc
ebenso wie stuttgart gegen wolfsburg das
abendspiel hoffenheim freiburg
ausführlich im sportstudio gestern union
berlin gegen fürth 1 1 montag noch zwei
spiele die tabelle die bayern stehen ja
schon als meister fest keine
veränderungen bis zum fünften platz köln
auf europa league kurs die zweite hälfte
beginnt mit eintracht frankfurt in der
abstiegszone ist hertha bsc nach dem
remis und dem punktgewinn heute als
fünfzehnter schon fast durch vier punkte
vorsprung vor dem relegationsplatz
stuttgart und bielefeld hoffen noch
keine rettung gibt es mehr für kräuter
führt ja der drittletzte spieltag im
aktuellen sportstudio um 23 uhr zu gast
vor seinem abschied aus der bundesliga
rudi verlangt und die basketballer von
bayern münchen besiegte im viertelfinal
play off spiel der europa league den
titel favoriten fc barcelona
überraschend mit 59 zu 52 damit steht es
in der serie best of five 2 zu 2 dem
münchner verteidigten herausragend und
holten schon früh einen zweistelligen
vorsprung heraus am dienstag findet in
barcelona das entscheidende fünfte spiel
um den einzug in das final turnier statt
noch nie konnte ein deutsches team die
runde der letzten vier erreichen
jetzt live zurück zu
werden was für unerschrockene ein
bisschen nervenkitzel bietet diese neue
brücke in vietnam der boden ist aus glas
und besucher können wenn sie wirklich
wollen 150 meter tief in die junge
schlucht blicken mit
632 metern ist es nach angaben der
betreiber die längste glasboden brücke
der welt das soll einen eintrag ins
guinness-buch bringen und viele
touristen
nicht überall bleibt der erste mai
trocken mehr dazu hat gleich osten
taliban wetter das heute journal gegen
viertel vor elf mit mitri sirin danke
für ihr interesse wir alle wünschen
ihnen ein schönes wochenende und sind
morgen wieder da auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter unser satelliten
film zeigt die wolken eines höheren
tiefs was sich heute über deutschland
ein gedreht hat es hat kräftige schauer
und gewitter gebracht und teilweise
sogar dauerregen am freundlichsten war
es noch nach osten jesus grün
durchschimmert da schien die sonne in
der nacht wird es weiter regnen das tief
verlagert sich richtung süden sonst aber
lockert es vor allem im norden auf
insgesamt aber immer wieder wolken dabei
aber trockenes wetter bei tiefsten
temperaturen von zwei grad richtung
vorpommern und 8 grad im süden
deutschlands morgen dann erst einmal
sonnenschein und das auch nach südosten
hin aber im tagesverlauf bilden sich
schauer und einzelne durchaus kräftige
gewitter mit starkregen möglich sonst am
sonnigsten noch an den küsten ja und die
temperaturen erreichen höchstwerte 11
grad an der nordsee 12 grad an den alpen
das sind die tiefsten höchstwerte und 19
grad in der niederlausitz ja und die
nächsten tage hauptsächlich im süden
dann immer wieder schauer und gewitter
örtlich kann es auch mal kräftiger
ausfallen am montag zum beispiel zwölf
bis 19 grad und mittwoch 12 bis 21 grad
ein schöner ab